this is a production of cornell
university
so today we're going to be examining the
physical properties of soil
and as we mentioned before most of soils
are made up of three particle sizes
sand which is the largest size silt
which is a very small size of sand if
you think of it that way
and clay which is the very smallest size
particle which is wafered and
cannot see it to the naked eye so
the way those particles come together
sand silt and clay
gives us the texture of the soil texture
is actually the
percentage of sand silt and clay in any
particular soil
why this is important is that the way
the particles come together
give you the porosity the amount of pore
space
that allow water to move in the soil and
so this demonstration is
aimed at showing you how water moves in
different
textures if you like of soil using
sponges
as proxies for soil and as you can see
this
this kitchen sponge is just uh it's got
core space
it's got solids it's got air which is a
good proxy for soil which is
about 50 solid 25 water and 25 percent
air
in a idealized situation so we can use
these
sponges with different pore sizes to
tell us how water moves
in soils so what i'm going to do here
first
is take this kitchen sponge and put it
under water
and squeeze all the air out of it
and then i'll let it open under water
and then i'll bring it up into the air
and the point where
there's no more air in the sponge but
just water is called saturation
saturation is when all the pores are
filled with water but of course as soon
as i
bring it out of the water it starts to
drain
drained by a gravity gravity is pulling
the water from the sponge
down we've still got plenty of water in
the sponge
but it's not even though gravity is
still there
it's not being able to pull more gr more
water from the sponge
at that point if we could
assume that this drips are stopped we
call that field capacity
which is the amount of water a soil can
hold
against gravity basically hold within
its pores
so we have basically this is field
capacity now
basically most of the water is gone free
water has gone by
gravity what i mean free water is the
water in the big
pores which called macropores that are
free to move via gravity
the water in the small pores called
micropores
are being holding onto that water so
that they're not able to be
taken away by gravity so then i say
let's just
field capacity this is the amount of
water this sponge or this soil can hold
if we want to say well now it's able for
the roots to get that water
from the soil i'm going to pretend on my
root but i'm just going to squeeze the
sponge
so i'm a root getting the water from the
sponge which would be
by osmosis but we're just pretending
so i'm just squeezing the sponge
until i can't really squeeze any more
water out of it
and there's still plenty of water in
this sponge
as you could all imagine but it's held
so
tightly by the pores that roots are not
able to
get that water by osmosis and at that
point we call this
the permanent wilting point where the
soil has water in it but it's held
so tightly that roots cannot get the
water
so between field capacity which is after
gravity drains the free water away and
where i've squeezed the water and you
cannot get any more water off of the
sponge
we call that the available water holding
capacity of the soil
that's the amount of water in a
particular soil and it varies from
soil to soil can hold against
gravity and was holding so tightly in
the pores that
roots can't get it so different soils
have different
available water holding capacities i'm
going to take this other sponge here
which is a yellow big really big pore
sponge you can see this sponge here
it's much more
open than the orange sponge i'm going to
open it under water again as i did with
the orange sponge squeeze all the air
out
let the water fill the pores and i'm
going to
see what the so much more water is
coming out by
gravity than the orange sponge
because there's lots of big pores which
allow water gravity to
pull that water down the small pores
hold the water
the big pores allow the water to go down
and then if i were to squeeze this
sponge there's not very much water
that's actually left in it
and in fact the available water holding
capacity of this sponge would be much
less
than this sponge so the the why is there
still water
left in the sponge after i squeeze it
that's because of the forces of adhesion
and cohesion cohesion is the
attractiveness of water to itself water
tends to bead up
when it's on a surface
but adhesion is the attractiveness of a
solid surface to water
and this is critical when you have small
pores there's lots of forces of adhesion
holding the water in the pores where you
get further and further from a solid
surface like in a big pore
the water is then able to move via
gravity
because the forces of adhesion are being
overwhelmed by the fact that
the water is further away from the solid
surface
it's interesting to look at
uh some different side different types
of sponges to see what kind of water
holding capacity we can actually measure
so i have three sponges here i have a
kitchen sponge like the orange one
and i have a the one yellow one like the
very big poor one
and i have a white sponge which has very
very small pores in it
very small so it's actually and i kind
of tried to
cut them so they're equal volume because
that would be important
more volume more water so i'm going to
do
the the same thing we did before i'm
going to squeeze the
sponge under water we'll start with the
kitchen sponge
let it come out under water and we're
going to see what so that's the amount
of water that's
being uh drained via gravity the big
pores are
are basically not uh are this just
letting their water go through the
sponge until we get to a point where
water is being held so tightly in the
sponge
that gravity cannot pull it away
and we want to measure so this again if
you recall this is field capacity
where free water is drained away via
gravity that means the water in the big
pores
and what's left is water in the smaller
pores which is being held
by adhesion by the adhesive forces
against gravity
so let's measure what let's see let's
get this out first
measure what was held
in that sponge
until i can't squeeze it anymore against
gravity
this is what it's called the available
water holding capacity i'm just going to
make it
slightly pink so you can see it in the
graduated cylinder
and we see we have 90 milliliters of
water
okay let's look at the other sponges we
can predict
if that orange sponge has really big
pores
that most of the water be left will be
moved by gravity and we wouldn't have as
much
held by adhesion after that well we'll
see
because this is science we're going to
squeeze the orange sponge
under water let it fill all the pores
with water
and then we'll let it drain by gravity
until we have no more water
draining via gravity and then all the
water in the sponge is held by the
adhesive forces of a solid surface to
water
so here we are now we're going to
squeeze this sponge
which has the biggest pores into
this tray i'm going to
we're gonna color it so you can see it
i'll take this other graduated cylinder
i'm gonna pour the water into this
so here we see that the available water
holding capacity is much less
because the big pores are allowing water
to move via gravity
and so we have about 60 milliliters of
water here
versus we had 90 in the medium size the
bigger
the sponge with more pores
more smaller pores i should say now the
third sponge
is this very tight very small poured
sponge which i'm going to
squeeze under water
and let the all the air out let the
pores filled with water
and now i'm going to so very little
actually is
pulled via gravity because all the pores
are very small
holding the water to their solid
surfaces
let's see how much water this
sponge holds
and you would predict that this would be
the one that has the most water holding
capacity because
all those small pores are holding water
very tightly
so let's measure that
so now we're at 120 milliliters of water
for the sponge with a very small pores
or the soil with very small pores which
is a clay or salty soil
where you can say that the green sponge
would be more like a sandy loam
had more sand in it bigger pores and
the orange sponge would have been mostly
like a sand have very little water
holding capacity
all this is doing is telling us how
these soils act
in regards to water water movement and
water
retention in terms of what the plant is
going to use for available water holding
capacity
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu